a former heights funeral home employee
is describing conditions inside the
funeral home was put on a six-month
suspension by the state for a number of
reasons including the mishandling of
bodies thank you for joining us at six
i'm brian loftis and i'm denise valdez
joe moeller spoke to an employee he is
live near sunset and boulder highway
with what he had to say tonight joe
trayvon thomas says while working here
at the heights funeral home he was also
working at another funeral home here in
the valley and watching how both were
operating he says he knew something was
wrong
when i seen these babies being stacked
on top of each other my heart dropped
rayvon thomas said enough was enough i
always said like what if families came
in here and saw what you were doing with
their loved ones thomas says he's worked
in the funeral business for five years a
year and a half at heights and was fired
in july i called the labor board and i
called the funeral board i even caught
the clark county coroner's office and
got you guys put off rotation and when i
told him that it was over thomas claims
he was let go for threatening to report
problems he shared videos and photos
with me he says are from heights most
too graphic to share you'll have another
picture where the bio waste bags are not
in the bio bins one video shows what he
says is embalming happening in the wrong
area another shows someone sawing a
metal shelf with sparks flying on bodies
stacked below another shows what he says
are babies stacked on a shelf the law
says that human remains must not be
placed on other human remains you'll see
that there's at least five or six babies
stacked on top of each other he says
record keeping was also a problem we
asked him if it is possible that people
have the wrong remains yes it's people
out there that's probably not even their
loved ones sorry to say
yes definitely thomas says he called the
funeral board numerous times but never
filed a complaint online the board says
that needs to happen for action to be
taken they need to be shut down period
now back out here live i did reach out
to heights today a few times and we did
not get contacted back the board tells
me they are still overseeing the
suspension process bodies must be buried
cremated or transferred to another
facility by later this month reporting
live in henderson joe muller 8 news now
joe you know thomas touched on it there
in his story but you know is there a way
for someone to find out if the remains
they do actually have are the right
ones yeah i actually brought that
question up to the board earlier today
and they said there actually are
companies out there that will test the
dna in ashes but the likeliness of there
being dna to test in those ashes is very
low i'll send it back to you all right
thanks for the update